pour ce Mondial de l'UTO 2012 de Paris
encore une fois les 270 marques
présentes rivalisent d'ingéniosité dans
le domaine de l'électrique et de
l'hybride tour d'horizon des
constructeurs installés dans les
ivelines on a une offre la Peugeot la
lion voiture tout électrique mais une
voiture tout électrique encore
aujourd'hui inévitablement présente de
réelles contraintes d'autonomie donc une
voiture électrique et on pense nous pour
encore quelques années quand même sera
forcément concentré a une un usage quasi
strictement urbain on croit beaucoup
plus dans la technologie de l'Hybrid
diesel on va pouvoir proposer des
voitures comme une 3008 hybride 4 et
bien qui fait 200 chevaux qui propose
quatre roues motrices et qui est
homologué à environ 4 l 5 de diesel au
sang la marque française porte aussi un
intérêt tout particulier au pays en voie
de développement elle présente cette
année une berline 301 réservée au marché
asiatique ruses et africain direction le
stand de BMW le constructeur allemand
présente cette année sa nouvelle marque
écologique explication avec le
responsable France vous avez sous les
yeux les BMW i8 Concept et i3 Concept
qui sont à 80 % à peu près identiques à
ce que seront les modèles de série dans
un an ces voitures sont faites pour
l'électromobilité avec des matériaux
ultra légers comme la fibre de carbone
ou l'aluminium et en plus totalement
responsable de l'environnement puisqu'on
utilise beaucoup de matériaux recyclés
euh sur ces deux voitures les premiers
véhicules seront commercialisés fin 2013
chez Ford c'est une grande première le
constructeur américain s'apprête à
commercialiser deux véhicules
électriques et hybrides en France ces
modèles étaient pour l'instant
uniquement disponibles aux États-Unis où
le marché de l'électrique et de
l'hybride représente 5 % du secteur
automobile on présente une Focus 100 %
électrique donc là vous n'avez pas de
moteur thermique vous avez 150 km
d'autonomie c'est parfait pour un usage
urbain ou périurb ain ou pour des usages
professionnels et à côté on présente une
Mondeo hybride qui elle va être parfaite
pour voyager parce que vous aurez une
hybridation c'est l'association d'
moteur électrique à d'un moteur
thermique qui vous permet en ville de
baisser considérablement les émissions
et les consommations mais malgré tout
d'avoir beaucoup d'autonomie pour
voyager qu voulait voyager loin et en
famille on pense que les moteurs
thermiques ont encore des progrès à
faire et notamment chez nous nous avons
développé un moteur bicylindre qui
s'appelle le twin nous travaillons
également sur des carburants alternatifs
faut savoir que Fiat est leader en
Europe sur le GNV le méthane donc des
c'est c'est un carburant encore plus
propre que le GPL et nous avons aussi
une large gamme de véhicules GPL la 500
électrique sera mise sur le marché
américain l'année prochaine l'Europe
devra encore attendre on termine avec
l'umé néo une PME des Yvelines
spécialisé dans le véhicule électrique
l'électrique c'est l'énergie du futur
pour la ville pas pour les grandes
distances c'est évident on un problème
de Capacité de batterie mais pour la
ville c'est c'est vraiment l'énergie du
futur parce que pas de pollution pas de
bruit
facilité de de pompe à essence aussi
dans la ville faut y penser c'est quand
même pas si facile que ça les progrès
techniques auront lieu d'abord sur le
poids du véhicule qui qui baisse tout le
temps et aussi sur l'autonomie grâce à
de meilleures batteries mais là le saut
technologique sera fait plutôt dans 3 4
ans ou voire un peu plus sans oublier la
T de chez Renault le véhicule électrique
en autopartage pour l'instant
exclusivement sur le territoire
cquantinois